there's a growing threat that cartels
criminals terrorists and other malign
actors will try to exploit this
situation for their own gain and we must
not let that happen we will never let
that happen today the United States is
launching enhanced counter narcotics
operations in the Western Hemisphere to
protect the American people from the
deadly scourge of illegal narcotics we
must not let the drug cartels exploit
the pandemic to threaten American lives
in cooperation with the 22 partner
nations u.s. Southern Command will
increase surveillance disruption and
seizures of drug shipments and provide
additional support for eradication
efforts which are going on right now at
a record pace we're deploying additional
Navy destroyers combat ships aircraft
and helicopters Coast Guard cutters and
air force surveillance aircraft doubling
our capabilities in the region very
importantly our forces are fully
equipped with personnel protective
equipment and we've taken additional
safety measures to ensure our troops
remain healthy